you
all right this one is just underway a
small group of 25 for a 300 blitz
tournament sandwich is there and round
ones are berserk
I will not be projecting back I need all
the time alright let's maintain my D for
point
an extra fast and here I guess they're
going to challenge me huh
let's drop back
I'm really going to take tonight let's
just go here though
for a start
I may try to play against this pond may
in fact let's try this so let's go for
this variation with Queen 83 alright
first things first we're going to take
like this I think is best
okay so this I can still do that move
well they go too
consider
trying to play again
their Bishop if I control these two pawn
breaks the bishop doesn't see my side of
the board
III or b4 let's go be for maybe circle
into c5 okay let's get out of the line
of fire
I'd also worry about this now I could
Castle kingside
let's just support this
let's take towards the center let's
castle a files open the rooks need to
play next up 95 I thought at least let's
get the knight on c5
playing very fast offering a draw
I'm going to decline I don't want to
draw
goodnight versus bad Bishop's sort of
I've control over these two I'm not sure
which square is best
who
come to the Queen exchange yeah maybe
clean here 95
here why not
jump in there
sup - to be honest
he's a struggling to find a productive
role okay
so this is this should be an excellent
ending it's not allowed d4 so easily
let's play here first okay
I'll come back over with d4 offering a
draw gun probably won't be the last one
either let's go to I would want to do
this and then here but they go into this
Square real quick so let let's shut down
the bishop first now let's do this if
look here okay let's stop their plan
okay let's take let's take intro look on
the seventh let's give a check get my
other rook on the seven
let's go here let's not trade too much
and hang on it up on if I can you
probably can't track that pond down all
right I feel like I just have to time
burn this player yeah
okay well objectively I was a drawn
endgame but didn't have enough time at
the end
take it they were very draw happy player
come across those from time to time they
super excited about draw draw draw stuff
so we got 232 are in this sack of
Sasquatch has two games in already
berserk in the first two who did he play
Wow alrighty that's a fast six points
consume we get around to okay
Chris Brown let's try you four
caro-kann huh
try to nights I guess alright Bishop air
for me yes so how do we treat this
position okay so closing shop in the
center ok I'm going to recycle my knight
- d - I'll get my bishop out first in
the d3 yep so this is the structure I'll
be playing with and f4 is what I'll be
looking for maybe maybe a quick Queen e2
and then f4 yeah let's let's do yeah
let's do this right now I may want to
hold off on Knight here because on f4 it
takes I think this is the most
convenient recapture I'm just going to
go one step I go to then this this is a
square that the knight could camp out on
let's go all the way back I don't want
to invite this pawn to move forward with
an attack
[ __ ] I have more support will they
play this no okay so they could get the
bishops you know they could get rid of
the bishop pair Trump but some of the
LightSquared bishop this is something
interesting I want to make sure that
positions open up don't want too many
instances of fixed pawns
Bishop pair so we'll go about it like
this tonight on f3 if I take I think
I'll take with the rook so I have a spot
for my other brooke to get tough one and
double and take all my pieces into
account so they're thinking some for
pretty much the first time
I think the way forward is to sake move
forwards of rook hit the bishop there
may be some sacrifices against h6 and
actually with this last move I should
have considered more of this move fact
let's try now I'd love to see that
this is excellent now for me
sure there's no fancy stuff with v3 I
think this is a moment where I could I
have a lot of time to do whatever I want
so let's see my bishop here there's
nothing fancy happening around here
that's just to check I trauma King in
the corner and soon I think the pressure
against f7 is sure does seem it's like
it's close to unbearable so here we go a
lot of pressure can't really ask too
much more of my Brooke
let's just stop any beats remove
completely static queenside structure
and I think I could get away with
launching my GH pons my queen will cover
these squares a queen on g2 actually you
know let's go here first
try and give it to my bishop let's hang
on him
you need to go here at a later time this
night the greatest piece I probably
should have tripled up on f7 I shot it
probably should have put it you know to
point where the night couldn't move and
if you did I would crash to run f7 okay
this look is unprotected simply like
clean let's take
and I guess we're going to take with the
Queen stay doubled here I want Queen f8
and rook here let's improve the King
first
okay now let's get the bishop playing
they were on a little bit of a standoff
there
giving a check first I'm trying to mate
in two right now he probably has to
return huh let's go back for a second if
the knight goes back here I have Queen
there let's just do this yeah
okay I don't
having to do this not at all
I want my king here and dropped a pond
I'm on the hook I'm on the rook oh I had
the rook
can have a rook exchange
now I have this oh they took with the
rook okay could enter with my king now
and he's under control could probably
just premium the push poni resigned yeah
I had a free rook there for a second in
that
a bullet load position all right we got
two games in there we have some fire 37
are in this now sack of Sasquatch now
has 10 and he is in a game let's see
what we get in round three
Alf void ok let's try a night of 6
six I play maybe the nimzo-indian and
Vogel Indian too much let's try to get a
blend I'm a fan of this positional line
this is a dark square strategy I'm
employing right now let's go immediately
with you five that's right here is to
take and then quickly jump in there so
I'm doing this to secure c5
this kind of stuff lets castle first
now I'll take sometimes I would just
voluntarily capture but I certainly do
not mind being provoked and then doing
this so there's that move
I think I need to get on with kingside
play take with the phone
these guys are controlling a lot
where's interesting Bishop move I think
that's sort of backfires he has to go
back here now actually he's now trying
out sighting this pond
a bit of a nice active move I don't
think she could be chased away so easily
so let's just get there I'm not sure
what I want to do here here both are
interesting this is with tempo this one
takes more into account the LightScribe
bishop and a nice blend of control over
both color complexes ties in well with
this guy
uhh
h8 rook g8 bit on the slow side but
maybe not bad also this gives up God
square so more inclined to go with E for
then F for I believe in this position
maybe I go with none of the above
how about night here in te form what
about this ad art offering a dark square
bishop exchange you know what I think I
like that idea
yeah they have the bishop pair so
think I'm successful I think I gained
just a little bit
so
versus an item bishop
the bother I have c7 covered what I
would really like is to be able to get a
foreign and clamp down on the B for
advanced and actually this is now my
moment to do that because on before I
get to take take and then take the rook
actually after this captures captures
the Queen from that one position has
been overloaded having to watch over
both bishop and rook so now I have a
serious positional threat but they're
still ready
don't just crash through here
okay well could I still do that
it's one a
could uh sack up on or something
be four and then run over here that's a
good move Bishop c2 is a good move I'm
going to go with thee for to control
both the bishop not give up this square
with f4 and on this I don't want the I
don't think I want the a file to open up
on B form prepare to go back to a5 on
Tom takes I'm fine with gambling upon
because I just want the c5 square for my
knight
if any of these pieces leave from
control over a four I'll play a foreign
lockdown on this structure and is uh if
I get a far in I'm securing my my pieces
on the c5 square they're also under
fifty seconds
take some care over my dark squares if I
go in the corner clean here I grab a
little bit of space
this is now my moment to get this in
so I can rely upon this night now and
[Music]
this just feels like a nice active move
[Music]
my queen I don't want to get in my
Khan's way I might want to push him
thinking about this I'll be fine with a
queen exchange okay I guess that's what
we're going for and I should probably
get my king playing right away
35 seconds my king
this kind of stuff as well target B -
let me first reinforce my furthest
advance pawn Casey struck out and maybe
improve my King just a hair I am within
striking Needham and I can now strike at
me but I could take here and my king
Believe It or Not can now fork the
knight upon now they just dropped a
piece and time pressure
I'm pretty sure that their rating has
yet to catch up with their actual
strength played much better than their
rating still has a question mark so
probably just not accurate just yet
and they don't have any time left good
game
yeah you won't see their their rating at
that point for too much longer
okay I am at eight we got 20 in first
sack of Sasquatch is honest hair five
games in already a Lance 5,500 YouTube
now there's a Lance just 5500 and now a
Lance 5,500 YouTube same person I don't
know what the story is
it's the marathon machine guy let's try
for this see what Lance comes up with we
go Bishop here yeah I think Bishop f5 on
Bishop g4 there's a quick h3 let's just
back up so at any point I could kick
this night away if they try to get an e4
let's get an e6 I can't do without that
Bishop here Knight here let's go with
the night here not sure where my bishop
belongs just yet
let's just put pressure on the night
maybe it's good to induce this I'm not
quite sure okay
takes yeah I'll take and then go here
and you know I would really like to
force this Bishop takes Bishop move
let's get here first though anticipating
some pressure
okay so I'll take care and I guess we go
with kingside castle very soon
or dunno maybe maybe I take here yeah
let's let's exchange LightSquared bishop
s' and now save this guy
okay
castles can't do without that
with the Queen yeah I'm going to
struggle some they're going to get
control over this only open file
um I guess here anticipating this move
okay I think I need to run it like the
dish and then scoop my King over very
very fast he needs to help out
and
think there's any other good square for
the Queen
I'll take with the night I think okay
well if they're going to do like that
now we take and scoot over again okay
now I have this move and my King might
actually run the entire mile here let's
say
boom boom keep going flush the RIC away
in the end I have a better Bishop so
that's what I'm really looking forward
to long term
good night versus bad bishop or good
versus bad bishop with stop night here
and now slowly improve my king
hang on c6 they're also down on time and
now improve the night
to improve the pawns maybe night here
nice very active now
by winning upon
good challenge that night let's go here
be winning now
didn't see that they have that but am I
not getting some pawns here you know
they're down on time take another pond
now I can have a past H pond let's put
the bishop on this diagonal
there passed upon I think I need some
dark square control maybe not
one of them was going to be a liability
let's keep going with the pawns you
could take here go here flush the King
back I have a huge walls pawns
let's take like that scoop this pawn up
giant wall of pawns now and we could
just convert this no issue no stalemates
no stalemate and they're down on time
okay that's
found four we got 12 with fire sack of
Sasquatch six games in wow he's moving
fast
close to the halfway point
let's try a b3
Bishop to b2 III that move okay let's
start with c4 I might try some fancy
stuff with h3 and g4 some type of gambit
play let's start hmm
let's not get too ahead of myself
now you know I should just go into
normal waters and play against this pond
there are not this pond but this square
ePHI very weekend pointing my pieces
here
Queen c2 d4 let's go is d4 so bit of a
stone wall
Dutch put the bishop on you to Castle I
may invest another move just to get the
dark square bishop soft they could stop
it with Bishop to e7 okay let's let's go
for this this is directed at one day
establishing a knight on e5 this is
another position type where I'm trying
to play against one of the black minor
pieces namely this guy
I don't want him to trade off for any of
my pieces if I move my knight to be one
is before Queen c2 there is Knight here
so let's get this in I'm headed for the
e5 square with both Knights
let have
allow the LightSquared bishop exchange
this is a missus maybe getting a bit
annoying let's jump in the center first
done this before Knight c3 so I could
play 95 kick the night away and then
play Knight c3 they're kind of stepping
on one another's toes like even right
now I feel like a knight be one move is
available okay it looks really odd but
I'm going to do it I'm going to kick
this night away and this is a bit
questionable because I'm under
developing where my opponent is already
completely developed
but I'm looking for an f3 move and then
Knight d2 or Knight back to c3 even take
with the pawn play with c5 maybe this is
something a computer to do it's really
put into question this backward up move
okay backward up backing up move so
let's let's follow through here this was
the idea for
excuse me after maybe off for our next
let's go right here c5 Knight d5
maybe I could leave them welcome to a
queen exchange actually it
exchange happens these pawns are split
of course my pawns are split but this
Bishop isn't such a happy piece and
these Knights are a bit clumsy because I
take away the e4 square so I'm going to
take with the Queen if my structure is
going to be split I want to at least
have the Queen's off my king should be
pretty good on f2 I would anticipate a
valuable tempo against the bishop going
to this open file
I'm also under a minute challenging my
night straightaway I don't want that
exchange tonight is pretty good here
or is he okay jumping that pond maybe
okay how do i punish that is it
punishable right here maybe I pick up
the pawn did not see that
not to improve the king I should be able
to get this pawn back
maybe I could have gone
straight in for it I have a better King
position but I'm still down upon I'll
have a good square and c4 to stop entry
points by both rooks
and let's go I guess with this rook
maybe it's a good to keep this pawn
defended in some lines I could take
right away but let's uh I want to just
kind of build up the pressure
stay out of this move with tempo try to
go to c3 feel like he'll drop at any
point I want to I want to do it when
when I want maybe in the end I take with
the night and then threaten 97 with
check evening out on time I'm ready to
finally grab that pond back there
probably pretty serious threat so maybe
kick this night away first I think so
you're going to really jump in here
let's kick in Malloy
careful right here
captured there as well
on this pond tricky nights everywhere
this connect
I have this
rook exchange very
on the clock
Virgen I went this square for my king
patch pond
come on King
I double up
I came fast enough
we're going to find out
Wow
oh you got that one in the end on time
they promoted with check and with my
last pre move there was more time
they're going to get my queen with the
skewer
Wow they turned on the Jets with that
one the end lucky to get that one 16
with fire
Sky's not leaving from podium position
number 128 Lance is at 22
and jaea is in their third it's not a
fire okay he just slipped up
will I get okay so they were paired
Lance berserk them in one so I'll
probably get psycho sasquatch
or what I get lance again
find out
it's again
different opening
laughter let's try a five
and just e6
and let's go a six I'm going to take and
we go into an exchange French that Moho
let's close it up
let's get this in 9065
hmm that's certainly different
develop bring a night out Wow
so here
really you're allowing knight takes
Bishop
impressive man with check
holy cow let's take what the real keep
this file open
is no Queen check here I got that
covered what are they doing to combat
this this long-term I mean is that an
issue
a knight move and then a fork let's just
they're going to go clean here
either we offer a clean exchange
and we'll just go one step
oh man now they're trying dish
go clean here hitting the night tricky
tricky tricky
is another idea whoo let's try this
still might be that move
I take they'll take with the clean get
my clean to defended square still just
going in for that very odd play I
haven't seen so odd seems to be working
out though
can I not take the night now
don't understand I'm not in this
pin anymore
for a clean exchange
I will definitely decline that
right we're going to play Bishop there
and give that up I have excellent
coordination my bishop on c6 is
fantastic
bishop here right now
trap
nation
you
um look here I guess
I want to see some pond
okay now really glue all my pieces in
okay perfect cord
up-up everything
everything everything to stay
coordinated
check everything is going to fall
now stand lights no perpetual
here they're setting up some perpetual
you
no stalemates
huh they're down on time
some fancy stalemate trick that way had
there in the end with the king creeping
over there that was the intention
very odd opening play really weird
having all these like little tactical
tricks
man okay I got twenty with fire 28 is in
first still
this guy has fire as well John he's got
to two points
more than me 49 players in this one
let's see less than 18 minutes left so
few more games
John is paired against sack of sasquatch
alpha void again alright so I have the
white side let's try a 92 can I get a
quick efore in there I can they didn't
challenge me
put the fish let's let's get f/4 and I
might try for a quick 'if I've I might
try to go K so they're stopping that all
together let's get the night out so this
is probably a bad idea
yeah almost certainly a bad idea
maybe we take him up though maybe let's
castle they could hunt LightSquared
bishop i want to move the knight and
pick this guy up but they're going to
make me fight for that I imagine maybe
we sneak out here let's ask him a
question
can you give me the bishop that would be
really nice let's play here
g5 I can just take okay
mm-hmm
well
where
take
I don't have anything fancy here there's
always Bishop g6 I did not expect that
move why can I not just take on f4
because I have this covered I was
expecting Knight takes and defending f4
this cleaned will probably be some tempo
against the Queen I've pressure against
the bishop Hughes defended dive pressure
against c7 that's not a fun move for
them to play let's start with clean here
now the bishop will move and then
there's this
maybe this move is best done 93 into f5
i think my nights are pretty great pain
team black
yeah I think we can expect Bishop g6 at
some stage so maybe let's hunt the dark
square Bishop and I will get him he's
all mine let's take them and I just
damaged their structure as well no I
will go here because I'm pointing here
this isn't so much a threat because of
Bishop g6
okay
what about this move that should be
pretty a pretty annoying pin in fact I
might just know actually an h6 I can
take but even if there wasn't a pin I
think I'm prepared to sacrifice on h6 g5
okay so let's actually jump in takes I
take with the pawn this is a really
uncomfortable pin now I should be
winning Queen b6 is your way out I
didn't see that core is it your way out
I have bishop here to block
v6 Bishop III
big problem now h6 I could just take
I could just take care still on the
Queen check I block just want a piece
and on the clean
and we block
and then take here next Queen takes pawn
Queen Bishop takes here I'm on of seven
takes pawn here maybe I'm not
threatening this actually the bishops
there to defend
all right if I go here there's a clean
check let's take another pond
Elena
yeah oh I could have I could have played
here as well
you
I don't know here
um let's just offer a clean exchange and
maintain control over this diagonal
I just want to secure square for my
light square bishop
upon b3
of coordination everywhere else
10 seconds of
the clock so now I get this move in
Bishop to b3 and everything is
coordinated I don't care about dropping
my epon I should be able to take
advantage of that somehow like this
look here
I don't have this
I guess I could take and then take here
get to rooks
okay they don't have a
just one that rook
I made it a little bit too easy on me I
was able to scoop up that f-pawn I
really dodged a bullet in that opening
night with the night on D 2 and playing
f4 trying to get an e5 the reaction with
e5 was excellent so
I should do without that f4 move for
sure if I could be assured I'm getting
an e5 it's a different story but if I'm
playing f4 and they're able to reply
with e5 and I have my knight stuck on d2
like that I should shy away from that
setup
not a good
good set up there
right around the 10-minute mark 50
players in Lance is in a game that is
ongoing yeah actually he's ready to win
and he just won and we may get paired up
for a third time
maybe he just finished on a 24 he's at
33
let us see
he's probably been on a hundred percent
berserk rate yep and we got him again
alright so first time with team white
let us see
what to do
put a media pressure on that pond
let's see what Lance does there okay
we're going to go at c5 make sure d3 was
at night h5 necessary because now I get
to maintain my bishop controlling this
square okay I don't know if that's
correct because can I not play this
right now let's shoot for this display
in the center so what I'm going to key
in on is d6 I there's a big trade-off
here I have a little bit of Queen side
space I give up d5 but I could focus on
d6 that's what I'm gunning for right now
I want to trade dark square bishop and
plant tonight on d6
can I manage that think so trade and
jump in I guess he will be challenged
soon but I don't have to trade him off
this is a pretty reliable home for my
night
protection here I'm going to try to
undermine this point Bishop here is the
ID I guess
I shouldn't think
out supporting it with before I think I
need to get on with some other stuff now
maybe take this night play night here or
what about night here right now I don't
want I'm trying to play against a
LightSquared bishop so I don't want him
to trade himself off for anything right
now I'm striking at c6 this could come
pretty fast okay
Oh
Oh
[Music]
which rook here maybe I take and take
here in some lines
have to be careful about pawn grabs
can't do this
I could return here and think about d6
let's go here first activate another
piece let's go here
hi up d6 let's go back there well aware
of that little trick
let's try b4
the squirrel just dropped back I think
serve Him
if I had my major pieces on good squares
let's go back here
now they're not too
Challenge this night needs to now
actually I get to jump in here they get
to trade the light squared bishop okay
but a little bit of calculation here's a
little bit of calculation
there I'm going to play it much simpler
I don't want to have to calculate
they've been more practical here I
should still have an advantage
queenside play take my night anchor him
in there
[Music]
let's go here we're going to continue to
try and chip away at that night let's
start to restrict this night they might
cash out and give up the exchange I'm
expecting that
[Music]
I'm gonna need some more support over d4
avoid the exchange once more improve the
King
now I'm in trouble yeah I'm going to be
losing upon now
okay
in a very uncomfortable pin
can i untangle maybe I'm getting that
guy back
oh did not see that move
I am losing now
they mister mate they need enough light
square I was busted in that final
position they just needed to create a
flight square and then do the that Rick
b3 move anomalies a gonner and I think
they would have managed even though they
were under 10 seconds
because they had an outside past pond I
could have just cashed out and gave the
material back and I was a goner
five minutes left I'm at 28 with fire
hmm maybe this is a berserk game to try
and at least tie I'll probably get in
one more game anyhow but maybe this last
one is worth while the berserk to at
least try four
something let's see
try to get up to 33 at least Jean is
perfect
all right let's bruiser mr. berserk 100
Oh someone who did a quick resign ah man
I don't know about that
a quick resigner so now I actually have
a chance to win for jerking this last
game would give me
five and thirty seven okay we got to go
super fast
six so this is a player who is perfect
so far could take care and then here and
now probably challenge this night right
away
ah
let's challenge this guy
okay this is a very very good ending I
get to play against these two guys of a
nice light square blockade this is an
excellent position rook here rook here
just pile up on this point right there
clean trade would be nice I could take
this pawn but then they get the b7 pawn
could I always defend any pressure over
here with bishop f8 maybe Bishop f6
first so what are you doing about this
point
let's get my bishop on a pretty secure
square
[Music]
we'll take and have them try and work to
get that pawn back rook c4 supported
pretty well with Queen and rook
could do this I could defend my
background quick queen c8 in the end
extra takes Queen a8 queen c8 I defend a
six even she's a past fun
I'm going to have a clean exchange or
the Queen has to go back here a seven is
weird
okay and now my bishop can actually help
out to support this
I want my king like right here right now
threatening this on takes and then Nate
let's improve the King
I'm up a pond it's not the most healthy
of ponds but can I do a bishop exchange
I think I'm going to go for that down a
minute
I want my rook on a 5 in defending a
brook specific ending rook on 85 and
push the pawn away outside pass pond 125
left oh they can always notify me as
well
I didn't go fast enough to improve the
king
now I could at least get here with check
do I have time for this
let's go
I don't know
you know what I could end up with two
split pawns that are better than two
connected passed pawns
let's try this do push
rook here I should have done that even
the last move okay now this is winning
would they resign in this uh miss
position
you
on moose
they resigned they were nice enough to
resign there they could have known
afraid me there but they gave me the
wind
39:37 second place in the end fifty
players in all okay Lance took it home
100% berserk rate
39:37 35 31
all right see page two three four and
five that's everybody
already to the 49 of you good games all
okay
[Music]